alors si un jardin privé qui n'a pas du
tout été créé pour la visite c'est mon
propre jardin fait avec mon imagination
métamorphose c'est en référence au pays
d'oz le aux aides des métamorphoses ne
juge jamais les gens sur leur apparence
on il faut il faut prendre la
philosophie du compte pour comprendre et
un jardin ça change tout le temps
c'est un être vivant donc une saison il
va être comme si et l'autre saison il va
être comme ça c'est un jardin qui au
départ est partie sur des thèmes c'est à
dire que vous allez trouver le german
curé qui est maintenant un potager
qui fait partie de l'ue rgc patrimoine
ling lumier vous allez trouver des
massifs à l'anglais ce que j'appelle des
médecines de fainéants
c'est faux c'est ça demande pas mal de
travail quand même messe à l'anglais ce
veut dire vivace vous allez trouver des
aspirations pas mal d'inspiration
asiatique après je cultive beaucoup sous
les arbres les arbres pour moi c'est pas
du tout un obstacle
simplement il faut choisir il ya
certaines choses que l'on peut vraiment
pas mettre sous un arbre
j'ai installé depuis l'année dernière
beaucoup de rosiers au pied des arbres
parce que ça donne une floraison
aérienne
le jardin étant petit je ne suis pas
pour les jardins que de fleurs je trouve
qu'un jardin d'abord ça va devenir
beaucoup plus difficile d'avoir un
jardin que de fleurs demande d'eau
beaucoup d'entretien et il faut jetables
et sur les vivaces et sur les feuillages